beijing has entered the final stage of
preparations for the 2022 winter
olympics
with just 100 days left until the
opening of the games volunteers have
been recruited
test events are underway and metal
designs have been unveiled
with the support of the chinese people
and the international community we will
be able to overcome all difficult
challenges successfully complete
preparations and offer the world a
wonderful olympic event
unlike during the tokyo summer games
local spectators in china will be
allowed to attend but regulations will
be much stricter
organizers have released a so-called
pandemic playbook to control the spread
of covert 19. all participants including
teams and the media will be confined to
a tightly controlled venue bubble
vaccination is required those who are
not will face a 21-day quarantine that
lasts longer than the games itself
exemptions on medical grounds only will
be considered daily curved 19 tests are
compulsory those who don't comply with
the rules could be banned from the event
officials here say the 2022 winter
olympics will be the safest yet but as
organizers enter the final sprint toward
the games the country is battling a new
fast spreading outbreak of the
coronavirus delta variant targeted
lockdowns have again been imposed and
domestic travel discouraged
the latest outbreak has spread to 12
provinces and more than 200 cases have
been reported
authorities say 75 percent of the
population is now fully vaccinated
booster shots are being offered to
residents in the capital
[Music]
the coronavirus isn't the only challenge
organizers face
activists around the world are calling
for boycotts citing human rights
concerns and growing tensions with
taiwan threatened to overshadow the
event
beijing has dismissed all criticisms its
leaders hope a successful winter
olympics will underscore china's soft
power and position on the world stage
katrina u al jazeera beijing